hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers I had to admit
growing up I wasn't really a Power
Rangers kid I was more in that Ninja
Turtles x-men kind of crowd in fact when
the show first premiered I remember
saying to myself there's no way is it
going to catch on people can't possibly
be this student and this is why I'm not
in the stock market the show about six
blind teenagers who saved the world from
Japanese stock footage was such a huge
hit that they eventually made a movie
about them in 1995 and does it suck
balls major balls in fact the only
difference between the movie version and
the show is that the movie version
actually has a budget but instead using
it on mind-blowing special effects and
high-tech wizardry they use it to go
skydiving if I that's how the movie
begins with skydiving by someone through
a whole bunch of money at the producers
and they said yeah we're going skydiving
bring the camera along I'm sure we'll
fit it in the movie somehow and as you
probably would have guessed it's an
entirely pointless sequence now the
first thing you Power Ranger fans might
have noticed is the changing cast in the
film we see there's a black girl on an
asian boy but wait a minute wasn't there
originally an asian girl and a black boy
well the problem with that is that the
black boy was put in the black suit and
the asian girl was put in a yellow suit
not very political correct oh when the
producers realized racial stereotyping
isn't in at the moment they get rid of
the two actors saying there is an
intergalactic unemployment line that
need weighting in and replaced them with
the two you see now however the two cast
members that sadly remain the same are
bulk and skull the supposed bullies of
the group which I always found kind of
strange if they don't like the Power
Rangers and they're always picking on
them why do they hang out with them all
the time
might wanna flip those on the story or
some semblance thereof is centered
around a space traveling villain aid
Ivan ooze who's just a little less
annoying than read instead the Lucien
Ricky Ricardo of evil finally a real man
his plan is to hunt down and destroy the
power rangers intergalactic leaders
Zordon who despite having all the powers
of the universe still can't manage to
sync up his voice with his lip movements
just good to see you again - oh and i
forgot about his little assistant alpha
the best way to describe him is imagine
c-3po being even gayer than he already
is I know that's hard to fathom but
that's pretty much what you get things
start heating up when you starts
destroying Sorna for making him miss all
the years of torment earth has gone
through Inquisition ladies punch read
earlier I got in it that's kind of funny
so someone on his power is destroyed and
he's slowly wasting away to a festering
ball of nothingness but don't worry that
doesn't interrupt the Rangers skydiving
and rollerblading it does however take
away their mighty morphin powers that
seems to get their attention we may not
have our powers but we're still the
Power Rangers no I'm gonna disagree with
you there Tommy you see being a Power
Ranger implies that you have actual
power so without power you're just a
plain old ranger and trust me they're
not very powerful especially when trying
to protect picnic baskets alphabet'
tells them that the only way to save
Zordon is to find the great power that's
located on a planet far far away the
great power well what's that where they
come from how does it work well this
movie has far too many action sequences
to worry about tiny little things like
plot however it does take time to tap
into our emotional sides sargon you
can't leave us
ever since you came into my life you've
been like a father to us all yes I think
we can agree that Zordon has been like a
father figure to us all where are these
kids parents
I didn't seriously do they ever show up
are they so inattentive that they don't
even know that their kids are on another
planet fighting giant black chickens do
you think they even know that their kids
are Power Rangers how do you miss
something like that and just when you
thought this movie couldn't get any
lamer take a look at what pops up next
I am dosia master warrior of the planet
fetus how quiet what come on you can
find more convincing names as Star Trek
word jumble so apparently she fights off
the birds by swinging these two sticks
together throwing him into some kind of
hypnotic trance yeah how is that
supposed to put you in a trance just
taking two sticks and swinging them up
and down up and down up and down up and
down up and down up and down up and down
up then down up and down up and down up
and down up and down up you win this one
no see ya so she tells them that they
had to travel to a giant phallic symbol
that apparently holds the great power to
do that she dresses an in fashionable
burkas and gives them the power of the
new sacred animals you are the bad
fierce and unstoppable you are the wolf
cunning and Swift adder what's wrong my
frog yes a frog like the one you kiss
get a handsome prince what the hell is
that kissing is my superpower you
shittin me they get the strength of the
swing that I get kissing what kind of
bullshit is that don't let her get away
with that stand up for yourself maggot
hey bitch get back here where's my real
superpower
hi-hi-hi fought this man go into anime
so the Power Rangers set out on a
spiritual and enlightening journey which
I actually kind of like it's good to see
these kids look inside themselves and
discover their true spiritual essence
and what exactly do they
this journey of self-discovery they kick
some ass and they get their powers back
that's it
bullshit that's like telling a kid the
secret to enlightenment is punching
somebody in the face which isn't that
bad an idea right now as always the
Power Rangers have a thrilling gem robot
fight in the middle of the city the
traditional toy robot models are
replaced this time with CG replicas and
I never thought I'd say this but after
watching this metallic diarrhea I think
I actually prefer the toy robot models
there's also a subplot about how Ivan
who's hypnotizes all the parents in the
city and forces them to jump off a cliff
I'm sympathizing with them at this point
but don't worry there's a little 12
year-old boy who knows how to operate a
crane and a monorail where the hell he
picked that up
was there a how to handle heavy
machinery class in grade school if so
how did I miss that class the battle
eventually works itself up into outer
space when the mother of all finishing
blows is thrown oh did you just see that
we all good lesson for the kids guys if
you can't overcome your enemies just
kick them in the happy second they'll go
down like anyone else
top notch upon hitting an asteroid Ivan
ooze is destroyed in the Power Rangers
fly off to save Zordon but unfortunately
they're too late
Zordon is gone if only they had gone to
save him first instead of showing off
the brand-new fighting moves and special
effects if only
remember what we learned those who
possess the great power all things are
possible
no Tommy no that's crazy talk
come on can it be
is it possible
Oh
wait a minute the Glee power has the
ability to do anything can we just use
it to destroy Ivan ooze in the first
place this movie makes no sense
nothing about the Power Rangers does how
come the monsters always land in the
exact same city how come the city turns
into a candy whenever a fight seems
about to happen how come nobody
recognizes the Rangers even though they
wear the exact same colors every day how
come they always move like they have
Tourette's syndrome how can we read this
voice never sounds right how come they
dress up like NASCAR mannequins how come
it's sunny in space
how come alphas so gay how come Kimberly
so hot why why why I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to and why is that song so damn catchy